I do a lot of training for many  corporations and I conduct sales  seminars and I've heard all kind of guys  doing techniques and training people  techniques of how to close sales and how  to work within and begin to control the  sale and how to ask for the clothes let  me share something with you you can  learn all the techniques of the world if  you don't believe in yourself  it won't happen for you I learned all of  it so that's why I do a training called  focus on the seller you've got to focus  on you and as you convince you as you  sell yourself every day every day every  day you will begin to see a difference  in the things that you're doing selling  yourself on your ability to perform and  job to achieve a certain objective  telling yourself every day here go again  and I've got what it takes this is my  day and nothing out here is going to  stop  you  [Music]